o fogo
eu sou essa menina da foto
eu tenho 24 anos e eu nasci numa cidade
com aproximadamente 100 mil habitantes a
24 anos atrás e eu nunca tinha ouvido
falar a respeito de feminismo
eu nunca tinha ouvido falar nem a
respeito de igualdade de gênero ea gente
pára e pensa
a gente está dentro de casa a gente não
escuta falar a respeito disso a gente
vai pra escola
a gente não escuta ninguém fala a
respeito disso ea gente fica pensando
poxa mas as coisas importantes da vida a
gente aprende né alguém em casa deve
ensinar na escola a gente tem tantas
aulas sobre tantas coisas na faculdade
eu aprendi isso eu tive aula de
filosofia de aula de sociologia tiver de
antropologia de todas as dia vi a gente
nunca falou a respeito de igualdade de
gênero nem de feminismo e aí que um dia
eu estava nas redes sociais eu estava no
facebook e de repente recebi uma
notificação que estava dentro de um
grupo misterioso que alguém tinha me
colocado a uma liga sendo colocado
eu não fazia a menor idéia do que
significava eu fui ver era um grupo
sobre feminismo e aí eu comecei a rodar
a barra é pra ler o que estava escrito
lá pra saber o que aconteceu nunca tinha
estado dentro de um grupo feminista e aí
eu comecei a ler a respeito de mulheres
histórias de mulheres de vivências de
mulheres
eu nunca tinha me conectado daquela
forma com assuntos que eu vivia que eu
já tinha vivenciado e assuntos que eu
também não tinha vivenciado mas que me
tocavam e isso foi uma tsunami na minha
vida
isso mudou a minha vida foi um grande
divisor de águas ea partir desse momento
eu eu eu lembro que eu estava nesse
grupo quando entrei no grupo estava no
trabalho
nesse dia não consegui trabalhar naquela
semana
meu chefe reclamou do meu desempenho
porque também não consegue trabalhar
direito e aquilo foi me tomando de uma
forma que ultrapassar
ava o khimki o quem eu era e eu passei
não contestar e uma nova pessoa ali
estava nascendo
e aí eu entendi o que era o conceito do
feminismo porque infelizmente a gente
tem uma idéia um pouco deturpadas do
feminismo e muitas mulheres têm esse
medo né de se declararem feministas
mas o feminismo nada mais é do que a
idéia radical de que mulheres são gente
citando aqui uma frase da semana de voar
que é uma é uma importante iniciativa
as mulheres elas são consideradas fêmeas
e quando elas reivindicam seus direitos
humanos
elas são acusadas de tentarem imitar o
homem porque elas não são consideradas
humanas ea partir do momento que a gente
fala que a gente quer ser tratada como
igual ao que a gente não quer sofrer uma
violência de gênero uma desigualdade
apenas pelo fato de sermos mulheres é
porque a gente quer imitar o homem e aí
que quando esse mundo se abriu para mim
eu percebi que o machismo ele estava em
pequenas e grandes atitudes pequenos
grandes comentários pequenas/grandes
piadas criadas e aí a gente passa a
entender que existe uma chance em bola e
também que é imperceptível e agente
reproduzir isso ea gente acredita nisso
porque ninguém chega pra gente fala que
isso é errado ou pra mim pelo menos a
não ser que você tenha sido a grande
sorte de ter nascido numa família com
com princípios de igualdade de gênero
eu acho que isso também pode não ter
chegado pra você e aí que eu fiquei
enlouquecida e eu só conseguia pensar
nisso e eu entrava no grupo era o dia
inteiro e eu conversava com essas
mulheres conversava com mulheres que
tinham vivências parecidas com as linhas
e conversava com mulheres que tinham
vivências completamente diferentes das
minhas e que eu nunca ia saber se eu não
me conectar se com elas escutasse que
elas tinham pra falar e quais eram as
demandas que elas tinham e aí eu pensei
o que eu posso fazer
ora nesse momento pra analisar isso que
estou sentindo e fazer alguma coisa por
isso por elas por esse movimento
e aí eu estava me formando uma faculdade
de comunicação sabia trabalhar com redes
sociais
eu trabalho com o visual sabia de tal
vídeo fazer imagens a lei pronto vou
criar um projeto mas aí eu tentei voltar
na raiz da questão como eu faço para
atingir essas mulheres com essas
ferramentas que eu tenho qual é o
primeiro passo que a gente tem que fazer
primeiro pra deixar que essa mensagem
chegue porque não adianta só sair
pregando feminino batendo de porta em
porta lá você tem um minuto para falar
do feminismo que eu nem sei eu não sei
se vou ser bem recebida
sempre né e aí eu pensei eu preciso
criar um diálogo com essas pessoas e
fazer com que elas escutam o que eu
tenho para falar mesmo que eu tenho para
falar seja uma coisa que eu ainda tô
moldando mas eu precisava conectar essas
mulheres
e aí eu pensei no projeto 10 das
mulheres empoderadas mulheres muita
gente me pergunta porque 2002 seria o
número mínimo pra gente conseguir criar
um sistema um cadeia em rede e você
mulher que estava indo agora você aquela
primeira derrota lá em cima com a boca
aberta que está chocado e você falou meu
deus eu descobri agora feminina nos
contar a alguém e essas outras duas
mulheres de baixo pode ser alguém da sua
família pode ser uma amiga sua uma
conhecida e assim a ideia de empoderar
pelo menos duas mulheres
ela ia se formando como uma cadeia uma
rede e se a gente fizesse exercícios que
é simples são só duas
é claro que você pode fazer muito mais
pode fazer 1 milhão milhares o que você
quiser mas esse exercício mínimo eu
acreditava muito que podia fazer alguma
diferença
aí vocês não perguntam como como agente
poderá mulheres como a gente está
tratando de seres humanos não é uma
ciência exata
não existe a fórmula não existe um mais
um
e você vai chegar no resultado final
pobre isso ao longo do caminho para
muitas mulheres em poderá é você ter uma
simples conversa
às vezes ela precisa só que alguém
discutir ela fala e fala eu te entendo
eu entendo que você passa eu passo por
coisas parecidas ou apenas eu te entendo
poderá a mulher pode ser contratar uma
mulher que sabe que o mercado de
trabalho em algumas profissões ainda
muito fechado para mulheres
então se você tem a oportunidade de
contratar uma mulher que você acha que é
tão qualificado quanto um homem também
poderiam dela de alguma forma
então a gente descobre ao longo do
caminho como fazer isso e aí você para
você pensa mas eu acho que não precisa
dessa questão de igualdade de gênero eu
acho que eu também nunca sofreu nenhuma
violência eu acho que o assédio num me
afeta ou não vejo problema nisso
eu só queria dizer que a gente não
precisa muito longe
vamos atravessar o oceano está de
consciência de que não é uma questão de
só você precisar ou não
hoje no brasil mais de 554 mil meninas
de 10 a 17 anos estão casadas legalmente
a gente pensar aqui sete a cada dez
mulheres já sofreram ou vão sofrer uma
violência seja física emocional e
psicológica ao longo da vida apenas por
serem mulheres a gente também tem outro
problema e mais de 30 mil meninas no
mundo se casam por dia então quando
decide acabar 30 mil meninas teriam se
casado meninas quando eu digo menos de
17 anos
elas vão estar casadas contra a vontade
delas
então eu acho que se você ainda pensa
que esse problema não atinge
eu acho que falta você conversar com
alguma outra mulher porque com certeza
você vai encontrar uma mulher que
acredita que precisa disso e que está
pedindo por isso mas você não sabe aí
tiveram algumas pesquisas que fizeram
inclusive com mulheres periférica
falaram que 74% delas acham que
receberam um tratamento diferente na
criação por serem mulheres
quem foi criado com o irmão ou se você
não foi criada com o irmão você pode
perguntar para alguém que foi criada com
o irmão e ver se essa mulher sente
alguma diferença também por ter é por
ser mulher
uma diferença na criação dela 90% deixam
de fazer alguma coisa por medo de
violência então é um medo de você sair
na rua com uma roupa específica porque
tem medo de ser assediada tem medo de
ser estuprada tem medo de ser morta e 77
por cento delas acham que o machismo
afetou o desenvolvimento ou seja elas
deixaram de estudar por causa disso
porque elas tinham de cuidar da casa
porque a família delas o dever de cuidar
da casa é da mulher e por isso deixaram
de estudar e não tiveram o trabalho que
quiseram enfim de alguma forma afeta ou
afetou o desenvolvimento delas
e aí quando comecei a falar do poder e
muitas pessoas começaram a falar junto
comigo e é muito louco porque você chega
você cria um projeto e é como se você
estivesse falando pra nada
você dá um grito e de repente você tem
uma resposta
e aí muitas respostas começaram a
pipocar disso e na internet como um todo
as pessoas começaram a falar a respeito
disso
a gente tem exemplos de hashtags que
realizaram no ano passado e eu tenho
certeza que vocês viram alguma mulher
algum dia ou passar por uma situação de
violência ou denunciando uma situação de
violência ou vocês mulheres já passaram
por uma situação de violência ou de
assédio ou vocês conseguem sentir a
necessidade da igualdade de gênero na
vida de vocês
mas o que a gente faz
nesse processo o que eu gosto de falar
que é o primeiro passo que a gente
precisa seguir a quebrar um muro porque
existe uma coisa que é colocada na nossa
sociedade que falam que mulheres são
inimigas são rivais e toda mulher que é
o meu mal
só que essa não é uma competição que
teoricamente existe eu acho que o limite
de competição é saudável
mas diferente dos homens
a competição que a gente é aprendi que é
a verdadeira e que devemos seguir é
aquela que a mulher está competindo para
ser mais bonita a competir para ser mais
atraente
geralmente está competindo por um homem
então aquela ali não tem fica esperta
ela não quer meu bem ela tem religiosa
não dá certo e eu acho que esse é o
grande ponto porque enquanto a gente se
preocupar em ficar achando que o grande
o grande inimigo é a mulher
a gente não vê o verdadeiro inimigo por
trás disso
o que eu acho muito importante nesse
movimento
é essa consciência a consciência de que
eu preciso aproximar uma mulher
reconhecê la como semelhante e não só
isso é preciso criar uma ferramenta para
que eu possa conhecer outras vivências
porque a minha vivência é individual é
particular mas ela não reflete o mundo
se eu tiver a sorte de nascer
privilegiada a onde eu nasci da forma
que na ciência não foi obrigada a casar
com 12 anos
a gente precisa olhar um pouquinho à
nossa volta e ver o que acontece de uma
forma mais macro também e aí que entra o
conceito de empatia
a empatia você tem a capacidade de se
colocar no lugar do outro e tentar
entender o que o outro sente se
sensibilizar com isso sentir se sentir
tocado com isso sabe e junto com esse
conceito de empatia vem o conceito de
superioridade que é baixar esse muro e
vê na outra mulher uma amiga uma
companheira alguém que eu posso contar e
alguém que eu posso defender o que vai
me defender o que vai estar junto comigo
sabe já está no mesmo barco e aí entra o
processo de desconstrução
pra gente é o que é importante na
desconstrução é que cada mulher vai ter
a sua própria construção é uma coisa
muito individual a gente não sabe pelo
que a outra mulher está passando
a gente não sabe a forma que ela
aprendeu ou foi ensinado a pensar a
gente não sabe pelo que ela viveu ea
gente tem que fazer os devidos recortes
porque eu enquanto mulher branca que fiz
faculdade eu tenho os meus privilégios
eu nunca vou saber que uma mulher negra
ela passa uma mulher periférico a mulher
que não pôde ter estudo uma mãe eu ainda
não sou mãe mas eu posso fazer se de me
colocar no lugar dela sabe e eu queria
falar que eu tô aqui hoje representando
esse projeto mas eu sou muitas mulheres
eu não sou só a mãe na área que hoje eu
sou minha vó eu sou a minha mãe eu sou
as minhas amigas
eu sou todas as mulheres que curtem a
página eu sou todas as mulheres que
compartilham a página eu sou todas as
mulheres que mandam mensagem na página
que comentam a página que fazem aquilo
virá porque isso nem poderá fazer esse
trabalho em poderá e eu sou muito grata
de poder fazer isso e de ter esse
retorno e de conseguir de alguma forma
passar uma mensagem que eu acredito que
é muito importante que se tornou a minha
vida
e aí eu queria te deixar o convite pra
vocês principalmente para as mulheres
que ouviram as suas palavras e que se
identificaram ou ou não mas que pensa a
respeito disso
eu queria convidar vocês é empoderar em
pelo menos duas mulheres quando você
sair daqui
tenho certeza que vocês já pensaram em
uma mulher mais próxima quando eu falo a
respeito disso ou se não tem alguma
mulher sentada do lado de vocês eu tenho
uma mulher na frente de vocês ou um
abraço uma palavra de simpatia uma troca
de olhar
eu acho que isso já é bastante
importante e eu queria dizer também que
o que a gente tem hoje é uma construção
muito antiga né
muitas mulheres lutaram no passado a
gente ter o que a gente tem hoje porque
nada foi dado para as mulheres de graça
e tem uma frase que diz que os direitos
das mulheres eles têm que ser mantidos
ao longo do tempo porque a qualquer
momento
a gente pode retroceder porque não é um
direito adquirido eterno e quando me
perguntam você queria morar viver em
alguma outra época passado
e aí eu penso no passado eu falo não
acho que eu vou ficar aqui mesmo porque
é isso que eu acho que o presente eo
futuro vai ser muito melhor e que a
gente pense nas nossas filhas nas nossas
próximas gerações para quem não for
filha ou enfim que a gente pense que as
próximas gerações vão usufruir do
direito que nós não tivemos hoje
então se vocês puderem das mulheres
sempre que possível
obrigada